je suis tchat JP pity un modèle
linguistique développé par Oppenheim
basé sur l'architecture gypity 4 mon but
principal est d'aider les utilisateurs
en répondant à leurs questions et en
fournissant des informations sur divers
sujets mon savoir s'arrête en septembre
donc tu ne sais pas qui est le président
de la France je n'ai pas accès à des
informations en temps réel je ne peux
pas vous donner le nom de l'actuel
président de la France Emmanuel Macron
continue à occuper le terrain en
déplacement dans le Doubs le chef de
l'État a fait un détour surprise par le
marché de Dole dans le Jura où il a
échangé avec les habitants et les
commerçants dans une ambiance plutôt
conviviale il a notamment assumé de
faire des réformes impopulaires
l'embrouille smile connaissez pas c'est
s'engueuler mais en se respectant et en
souriant
se fout de ma gueule
c'est monsieur
le Président
on n'est pas d'accord mais il est
respectueux
bonne journée à vous
à vous rire comme mourir de rire bravo
bonsoir Florent petite Florence comme
prévu de tirer la tronche il faut qu'ils
aillent ailleurs parce que là ça va par
contre il rigoler c'est laxation c'est
la bonne adresse et n'oubliez pas que le
rire est la meilleure des choses pour
prolonger la vie en attendant la
retraite
on risque de l'attendre un moment
et cette contestation de la réforme des
retraites devrait culminer lors de la
nouvelle journée de manifestation prévue
le 1er mai on s'oriente vers une
mobilisation historique ce sont les mots
des renseignements territoriaux dans une
autre rédigée le 24 avril jusqu'à 100000
personnes sont attendues dans le cortège
parisien il y a une fumée Julien vous
avez mille-feu c'est le brouillard qui
permet de cacher les moucherons cette
année on va monter d'un cran de toute
évidence selon les informations du
Parisien de RMC Sport vous allez avoir à
ce moment là dans le public 30 000
cartons rouges qui vont être distribués
donc distribuer dans les réseaux de
transport ou à proximité du stade et 10
000 sifflets notamment par des syndicats
on y va je vous entrez tendu
détendez-vous c'est une première
détendez-vous allez ça va bien se passer
c'est tout
il va y avoir des grilles installés dans
les virages du Stade de France vous
allez me dire la grille du virage les
virages c'est loin de la tribune
présidentielle ah oui on apprend dans
l'équipe que la sécurité craint des
incursions sur la pelouse en raison du
contexte dit à la présence potentielle
d'Emmanuel Macron
vous avez des mains fait la vie c'est
bon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et je trouve que j'ai plus de facilité
qu'avant
on doit aider les gens qui sont démunis
simplement il y a des limites il faut
mieux les accompagner mieux contrôler
c'est ce qu'on va faire avec la réforme
on fait les deux ce travail
j'ai bien entendu ce qu'a dit le
président de la République Célia elle
m'a appris à faire des jeux de comédiens
à partir de maintenant je fais exprès
c'est tout vous inquiétez pas
il y a des pompiers quand même au cas où
donc je suis en train de se dire je suis
un petit Cardi la personnalité
je vais demander à Cruella bonsoir si je
pourrais avoir les phrases d'avant s'il
vous plaît on avait fixé les règles je
voudrais rentrer
oui alors là changer d'idée tout ça
franchement vous êtes non non
franchement c'est très gênant c'est
transmission pensée quand on est en
Bluetooth ou quoi là je est-ce que c'est
le rôle d'une ministre d'une secrétaire
d'État de poser dans un magazine de
charme un magazine Playboy qui véhicule
des clichés sexistes voilà c'est la
question est posée de cette manière la
réponse ne peut être que non moi je
propose la question d'une autre manière
est-ce que c'est le rôle d'un membre du
gouvernement de parler à tout le monde
tout le temps de répondre à toutes les
questions de considérer qu'à partir du
moment où il y a des gens qui lisent une
publication il est important aussi
justement d'aller dans cette publication
là c'est pas une bonne zone c'est votre
zone préférée
c'est fou quand même c'est vous qui
faites tout son rapprochement et c'est
moi le pervers
[Musique]
pas moi
je suis trop innocente évidemment je
suis un an je regardais oh
sorcière moi je me pose la question
savoir est-ce qu'on a posé ces questions
justement par exemple à Mitterrand à
Jacques Attali à Thierry Breton à Carla
Bruni qui ont déjà répondu à des
interviews dans Playboy ça n'a pas fait
un tel scandale je ne crois pas qu'on
leur est posé ces questions là
pratique pour faire le gai
rondelle
vous avez dit rondelle pratique pour
faire le gay rondeur
je ne dirai rien ça pourrait être mal
interprète
[Applaudissements]